search and rescue operations are
underway in the Ukrainian cities of Kev
and K following Russian air strikes
emergency Personnel have been going
through the rubble looking for survivors
in kiv residential buildings and cars
were damaged in the attack Robert bride
joins us now from the Ukrainian Capital
ke and Rob those casualties in
yesterday's attacks continue to rise the
biggest wave for
weeks yeah that's right this was an
extremely sustained attack targeting uh
various locations across Ukraine the
latest casualty figures that we have now
is that 18 people confirmed dead with
more than
130 uh people injured now these casualty
figures continue to mount as search
operations have been continuing well
into the hours of Darkness Tuesday uh as
as well as the actual attacks themselves
uh the Second City here in Ukraine H
they they uh sustained a third wave of
missiles late on Tuesday night uh a
total of 200 sites are reckoned to have
been hit across Ukraine with more than
100 uh residential buildings impacted in
one way or another some buildings of
course completely destroyed and uh
president vadir zalinski of Ukraine
spoke about this in his nightly address
talking about the complex mix of
missiles that Russia has been using in
attacks such as this one some 40
missiles he says were used a mix of
Crews and ballistic missiles and
concerningly for the ukrainians although
50% of those do seem to have been
intercepted that means of course around
half uh got through and this comes as uh
key allies such as the United States are
still holding back on uh Aid P military
aid packages worth billions of dollars
which include much needed uh Munitions
as this winter continues and Russia
continues its air campaign against
Targets in Ukraine Robert Brad Forest
there in keev thank
you